[Music]
we've become
chummy I'm gonna say chummy not really
not just in the commercial break
yeah no yeah you you came on one of my
incarnations in the television show at
one point and we and and I always I was
a fishing show yeah that was a fin and
then we started talking and then the
next thing you know we we realized we
have a connection which is my wife is
from Seattle right you and your wife
from that area and serratus City they
look good they're all excited the
Seattle people other yeah it's actually
the only part of studio where it's
raining yeah and so anyway we started
hanging out and you have a terrific
family yeah well we have you have two
kids at wooden you have two kids and
someone else has two kids they cancel
each other out so the parents can go and
drink and Conan got wasted I was wasted
when I showed up that's true one of one
of my speakers with like My Chemical
Romance blasting he's like don't
interrupt and then and then was it urine
off asparagus yeah clean this up somehow
and I I cooked for you you did man made
me fantastic steak you asked for the
recipe I did and I never have used it
how dare you cuz I haven't been able to
make it since I can't cook I cannot cook
why would you want the recipe I just
wanted to look like that's terrific I'm
like because my wife was so impressed
she was like that guy can cook I'm like
hey that guy has a name lady if you I
it's so always lady I didn't know your
wife played it was pretty wasted and
and then trying to get the keys out of
this guy's head so then I held his hair
back and if that tough was perfect but
it's my vomit Yandell right here sorry
look you all knew what show you were
signing up for when you tuned in you
knew
yeah I told not the toilet it's my boyos
bed but I did what I did she Mike wife
kept talking about what oh wow this is
an amazing steak and yeah I can't you do
that because I make two things I make
ramen pride noodles and I make tuna fish
with Miracle Whip mixed into it those
are the two things that I made in
college those are the two things I make
now I don't make anything else when was
the last time you made ramen noodles
like two days ago I love ramen noodle
it's not brick you drop it in boiling
water and then right
then it's the saltiest most amazing
thing you ever put your face into its
[Applause]
and then you act cool you open a little
packet
shrim that is you are really strange
when you cook no wonder you'd be the
strangest celebrity chef ever and you
know what I should do I would love to
have a cooking show where everyone Tunes
I try to get people to tune in every day
and I just make ramen noodles every time
are you made your tuna and the
mayonnaise like there's tuna mayonnaise
and then you pull out the finished bowl
they like seeing as Al Roker walks out
and starts eating apologize I can take
it